y
[Música]
con aplausos el parlamento de italia
celebró la reelección del presidente
sergio matar el a previamente el
mandatario había aceptado continuar como
jefe de estado luego de que los
legisladores no pudieran llegar a un
acuerdo sobre un candidato alternativo
tenemos reportes desde ropa
austria aliviará progresivamente las
restricciones implementadas para frenar
la propagación del cob en 19 en la
capital miles de personas salieron a las
calles para rechazar la vacunación
obligatoria en francia otra multitud
protestó en contra del llamado pase
vacunal que entró en vigor el pasado
lunes
la rotura de un oleoducto provocó un
derrame de petróleo en la amazonía
ecuatoriana el incidente ocurrió en una
zona montañosa amenazada por el proceso
de erosión regresiva del río coca un
fenómeno que ha obligado a cambiar la
dirección de varias tuberías de petróleo
tenemos análisis
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz
empezamos en italia porque el parlamento
eligió al presidente sergio matar el a
para un segundo mandato de siete años
el mandatario de 80 años quien ya había
manifestado su deseo de no continuar en
el cargo finalmente aceptó ser reelegido
los legisladores lo instalaron a
permanecer como jefe de estado debido a
la falta de consenso para escoger a un
candidato la elección de matar el asedio
en la octava ronda de votaciones en la
que logró el mínimo de 505 votos
necesarios de 2009 elegibles ahora se
convierte en el segundo jefe de estado
en ser reelegido luego de que en 2013
giorgio napolitano tuviera que hacerlo a
pesar de haber dicho que quería
jubilarse los detalles desde roma con
nuestra corresponsal natalia mendoza con
una fuerte mayoría de votos en el
parlamento italiano sergio mataré la ha
sido elegido para un segundo mandato de
presidente de la república por la
asamblea compuesta por los diputados
lores y representantes regionales de
italia este es el resultado de una
semana de caos político aquí en italia
de enfrentamientos entre los diferentes
partidos políticos incapaces de lograr
un acuerdo para votar a un candidato que
fuera aceptado por la izquierda y por la
derecha frente a este bloqueo los
líderes de los principales partidos
políticos italianos se reunieron esta
tarde con sergio matar el a le
solicitaron que se quedara al poder que
aceptara un segundo mandato matar el a
dios su disponibilidad se procedió con
este voto en el parlamento y con este
resultado pues ya es oficial es sergio
matar él ha sido elegido el nuevo
presidente de la república italiana con
un mandato de siete años
en europa a miles de activistas anti
vacunas salieron nuevamente a las calles
para protestar en contra de las medidas
de sus gobiernos contra el kobe 19 las
principales movilizaciones tuvieron
lugar en austria y francia-- rafael
pérez nos cuenta más en el siguiente
informe
activistas contra las medidas sanitarias
para contener el cob y 19 vuelven a las
calles de europa
en francia al menos 2.000 personas
salieron para protestar contra el pase
vacunal los manifestantes calificaron la
medida como discriminatoria
rojas destinarse en segregación el paseo
vacunales segregación a simple vista y
lo peor es que mucha gente apoya esta
segregación entonces que sigue sobre qué
base nos van a segregar esto se ampliará
a muchos otros criterios esta es la
primera movilización contra el proyecto
de ley que entró en vigor el pasado
lunes aunque la participación ha
disminuido considerablemente
en las calles de austria también se
sintió el clamor de los antivacunas
cerca de 10.000 personas alzaron contra
la disposición de vacunación obligatoria
que entrará en vigencia a partir de
febrero
todos aquellos que decidieron no
vacunarse se arriesgaron a que tal vez
enfermaron y tal vez no
nuestro cuerpo nos pertenece y así
seguirá siendo
la movilización sería en paralelo al
anuncio de reducción de las
restricciones en la próxima semana para
vacunados y no inmunizados sin embargo
aquellos que no cuentan con ninguna
dosis administrada se les mantendrá un
grupo de limitaciones para el ocio y la
compra de artículos no esenciales
en reducía el número de nuevos casos
diarios superó los 100.000 positivos el
sábado por primera vez desde que inició
la pandemia con 113 mil 122 contagios el
país registró su novena jornada
consecutiva de récord una situación de
la que las autoridades culpan a la
variante omicron entretanto en su vecina
ucrania las muertes por todo y 19
superaron la barrera de 100.000 al
tiempo que alcanzó un nuevo récord de
contagios con más de 37 mil
vamos a américa latina' otro derrame de
crudo ha ocurrido en ecuador este
viernes tras una nueva rotura de un
oleoducto en la amazonía dentro de una
zona montañosa amenazada por el proceso
de erosión regresiva del río coca
concretamente la empresa privada de
oleoductos de crudos pesados que opera
la tubería reveló que el incidente se
debió en parte a una combinación de
terreno debilitado y fuertes lluvias en
el área de piedra fina que hizo que
rocas cayeran sobre el oleoducto esta es
una zona cercana al volcán reventador
que mantiene una actividad eruptiva
permanente para hablar de este tema
saludamos a fernando cortez vivanco
ecologista y cofundador de estándar y
asamblea de jóvenes por la
sostenibilidad en ecuador' bienvenido a
france 24 ya hemos visto el desastre
ambiental que ha causado el derrame de
petróleo en las costas de perú y ahora
sucede esto en ecuador aunque con una
proporción mucho menor qué consecuencias
podríamos o podríamos ver en la zona
durante o donde se produjo este
incidente
bueno definitivamente este es un
fenómeno multidimensional no se ha
registrado como bien señala este a
partir de un proceso de la opción
regresiva natural y un socavón de tierra
pero esto responde a su vez a una
historia de una pésima gestión pública
alrededor del control ambiental y
también es una respuesta estructural de
cierta forma en el sentido de un modelo
económico insostenible e irresponsable a
partir de eso tenemos dos dimensiones
fundamentales de afectación por un lado
la dimensión ambiental teniendo en
cuenta que es un lugar de sensibilidad
ecológica con un alto nivel de
biodiversidad y por otro lado una
dimensión social que tiene que ver con
la salud con la afectación en cuanto a
la contaminación del agua y a la
soberanía alimentaria de las poblaciones
y de las comunidades aledañas
principalmente de pueblos originarios
señor cortes este suceso se da como
dijimos anteriormente en una zona
amenazada por la erosión regresiva del
río coco cuáles son los riesgos
bueno los riesgos fundamentales es la
pérdida de biodiversidad
en ese centro donde ocurre el fenómeno
es un centro que se considera un
ecosistema frágil entonces estamos
hablando de muchas especies de plantas y
animales que son fundamentales para la
mitigación del cambio climático no
entonces el riesgo fundamental aparte de
los daños sociales es evidentemente la
degradación ambiental que tiene como
consecuencia
una degeneración fundamental en un
momento histórico sin precedentes como
es el gran desafío del cambio climático
donde si no generamos una regeneración
ecosistema y cambiamos a modelos
económicos más responsables
definitivamente estaremos yendo a una
época donde se pondrán en peligro muchas
vidas y vendrá una gran migración y
fundamentalmente el nivel de vida y de
bienestar social cambiará de manera
drástica pues bien era fernando cortez
vivanco ecologista gracias por
acompañarnos aquí en france24 y vamos a
eeuu el noreste del país se vio azotado
por poderosa tormenta que ha dejado
hasta 15 centímetros de nieve en varios
territorios la situación llevó a los
gobernadores de nueva york nueva jersey
massachusetts y otros estados a declarar
el estado de excepción los meteorólogos
dijeron que la situación podría empeorar
y las autoridades locales han advertido
sobre cortes de energía e inundaciones
en las zonas costeras las aerolíneas se
han visto obligadas a cancelar un total
de 6000 vuelos
llegamos con noticias deportivas por
primera vez en 44 años una australiana
se corona campeona del abierto de
australia la número 1 del mundo ashley
bhakti esta vez sí fue profeta en su
tierra y se llevó su tercer título de
gran slam tras imponerse frente a su
rival estadounidense danielle collings y
remontar un segundo set que perdía 15
con la victoria ashley bhakti se sumó a
la estadounidense serena williams como
la única jugadora en activo en haber
ganado una competición slam en tierra
hierba y pista dura
[Aplausos]
en realidad estoy muy orgullosa de ser
australiana así que gracias a toda esta
multitud es la más divertida ante la
cual el jugador ustedes me han traído
tanta alegría hoy me relajaron me
empujaron a hacer un gran juego frente a
una campeona como daniel puede traer lo
mejor hoy así que muchas gracias por
todo su amor y apoyo en las últimas
semanas
hasta aquí en este informativo en france
24 para los invitamos a visitar nuestra
página web www punto 24 punto com para
seguir la actualización de nuestras
noticias gracias por acompañarnos
continúen con toda nuestra programación
[Música]